[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance
shortly after Trump lost the Iowa
caucuses The Washington Post wrote about
the supposed Trump whisper billionaire
conservative Tom Barrack he reconnected
with his old friend Paul Manafort a
longtime Republican consultant I really
need to get to Trump Manta Ford said
according to Barrack he told Barrack he
wanted to work as Trump's convention
manager helping him navigate what they
expected would be a contentious affair I
really need to get to Trump why ever
would Paul Manafort have put it that way
why ever would Paul Manafort tell a
friend of 40 years he knew this man
Barrack 40 years that he had to get to
Trump and he would convince Barrack to
send Trump and Ivanka Trump emails
encouraging them to let Matt affort get
to trump and the next thing you knew
Matt affort was high in the Trump
campaign and attending the Trump jr.
meeting with the Russian vessel nets kya
and then he was chairman of the campaign
and all of it for free why I really need
to get to Trump why I think we got the
answer last Friday evening Paul Manafort
has much stronger financial ties to a
Russian oligarch than have been
previously reported an NBC News
investigation reveals that 26 million
dollars changed hands in the form of a
loan between a company linked to Manta
fort and the oligarch Oleg Deripaska a
billionaire with close ties to the
Kremlin the loan brings the total of
their known business dealings to around
60 million dollars over the past decade
according to financial documents filed
in Cyprus and the Cayman Islands
why did manna fort really need to get to
trump well there are 60 million possible
reasons right there it's an old analogy
if you're outside in a thunderstorm at
night when the lightning flashes for a
second or two you get a picture of the
landscapes so vivid so illuminated that
you can almost see everything in almost
too much detail and then until the next
Thunder store
it's pitch-black again the apparent
Trump Russia conspiracy is a lot like
that we get flashes of insight with
never enough exposure sometimes too much
to truly see them for what they really
are and then for an unpredictable length
of time there's just darkness and one of
the things we've presumably seen but not
been able to process is evidence of why
the people around Trump allegedly sold
this country after the Russians not why
he would have done it you've seen him
now for nearly nine months in office you
and I both know he would do anything for
power or for spikes or for applause but
why would the people around him do it
why would they risk potential treason
actual legal treason or merely its moral
equivalent to put this baboon in the
White House hmm according to the Cyprian
financial documents the 26 million
dollars went from a company owned by the
Russian oligarch directly to a firm
connected to Manta fort and the same
Russians company issued a seven million
dollar unsecured loan to another Cypress
firm connected to manna fort and the two
cypress companies that got the total of
33 million from the Russian they in turn
loaned 27 million to a corporation in
Delaware that NBC also says is linked to
Manta for the companies called Jess and
LLC Jess and Manta Ford has two
daughters Jessica and Andrea Jess and
and the NBC piece is full of references
to possible money laundering and the
special counsel mr. Muller not only got
warrants to search Manta for its home he
got no-knock warrants that basically
permitted the FBI to break down his door
as a precaution against Manta for trying
to destroy evidence if they not I really
need to get to Trump almost as
interesting as these dangerously high
sums of Russian money manna fort was
reportedly receiving handling laundering
before he just had to get to trump and
become his campaign chairman for free
was the reaction to this NBC
story by Manta Ford spokesman actually
the reactions there were two different
reactions quote Jason Maloney declined
to give specific answers about the loans
but released a statement to NBC News
saying in part mister man afford is not
indebted to former clients today nor was
he at that time he began working for the
Trump campaign a clear and robust denial
except quote he later revised that
statement removing that sentence
entirely Maloney's second response to
the story of the 60 million reasons is
about how poor manna fort was under
surveillance and wild conspiracy
theories and he never colluded with the
Russian government and absolutely know a
thing questioning the reporting the
reporting that Manta Ford was up to his
eyeballs in 60 million dollars in
Russian money and could have been
somehow financially obligated to former
clients when he just had to get to trump
to work as his campaign chairman for
free last week Bob Muller's team
interviewed Wright's Priebus about Co me
about Flynn likely about the Trump jr.
meeting with the Russians and manna fort
last week the think-tank the Brookings
Institution issued a 108 page paper
concluding that Trump quote likely
obstructed justice in firing the FBI
director and the FBI director has
testified under oath that he was fired
because he wouldn't stop the
investigations of Trump and Trump's gang
and Russia the House Intelligence
Committee is reportedly now focusing on
and receiving documents from the company
Cambridge analytic
owned in part at times by Steve Bannon
and this right-wing billionaire and
Trump supporter Robert Mercer and
analysts at Oxford University in England
report they've discovered there was a
quote entire ecosystem of that
pro-russia propaganda on Facebook and
Twitter which was micro targeted
specifically at current and former US
military personnel I really need to get
to Trump resist remove
Pease the book is here we got a good
review from Kirkus Reviews which never
gives good reviews sharply focused the
prose is consistently aggressive
unrelenting invective for trump haters
who will love it
Trump is Epping crazy wherever books are
sold and it's now available without a
prescription